>> PEOPLE IN THE LAST FEW DAYS
OVER IN SECTOR 3 OR   MONUMENT 3
IS BEEN UNDER THE TERROR WATCH
LIST INDIVIDUALS THAT THEY HAVE
ON THE WATCH LIST FOR  TERRORIST
ARE STARTING TO EXPLOIT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
WE NEED TO WAKEUP.
WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND LISTEN,
MR. PRESIDENT BIDEN, YOU’RE AN
OKAY GUY.
WHY DON’T YOU JUST ADMIT YOU
MADE A MISTAKE WITH THIS POLICY
AND GO BACK TO THE WAY IT WAS.
THE DOOR SHOULD NOT BE OPEN, AND
WE SHOULD HAVE IMMIGRATION THE
RIGHT WAY.
AINSLEY: HE’S A REPUBLICAN, I
LIKE THAT HE SAID, YOU KNOW, YOU
SEEM LIKE AN OKAY GUY, A GOOD
GUY.
BRIAN:  HOW ABOUT THIS?
DIDN’T HE TELL US LAST WEEK WHEN
I MAKE A MISTAKE I WILL TELL YOU
I MADE A MISTAKE?
WELL THIS IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY,
MR. PRESIDENT.
THE REMAIN IN MEXICO POLICY
NEEDS TO REMAIN I DON’T THINK
THEY WANT TO BUY INTO IT ANYMORE
, BECAUSE THEY ARE TICKED
OFF AND NUMBER TWO IS THE
PROPOSITION 42 HAS TO GET
BAKKEN ACTED LET’S BRING IN
DAN BONGINO, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR SO DAN WHAT ARE THE
ODDS THE PRESIDENT WILL SAY
I MADE A MISTAKE?
>> YEAH, ZERO.
LIKE THAT
ROBERT DOWNEY JR. MOVIE LESS
THAN ZERO, THAT WAS A MOVIE
RIGHT?
IF I REMEMBER FOR ALL US 80S
KIDS OUT THERE.
IT’S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
OF COURSE IT ISN’T GOING TO
HAPPEN BECAUSE THAT WOULD
REQUIRE GUTS AND I’M SORRY BUT
BIDEN DOESN’T HAVE GUTS.
HE DOESN’T HAVE THE GUTS TO
STAND UP TO THE INSANE NOW
RADICAL LEFT.
HE DOESN’T HAVE THE GUTS, I MEAN
, LISTEN, GUYS.
THE COUNTRY’S FALLING APART
RIGHT NOW.
I’M REALLY SORRY BUT WE’RE IN
THE MIDDLE OF A CATASTROPHIC
DEBT CRISIS, WE’VE OPENED OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER RIGHT NOW, WE
HAVE AN ECONOMY THAT’S STILL
STRUGGLING TO GET OUT OF THE  DO
LDRUMS FROM THIS PANDEMIC
, WE HAVE BIDEN
RIGHT AS WE ARE TRYING TO GET
OUT OF THIS COLLAPSE AND I
KNOW IT’S IMMIGRATION BUT YOU’LL
JUST ALLOW ME FOR A SECOND,
RIGHT AS WE’RE GETTING OUT OF IT
THEY HAVE THIS GENIUS IDEA,
THESE DUNCES IN WASHINGTON D.C.,
WE’RE GOING TO GIVE YOU GUYS
STIMULUS CHECKS FOR $1,400, AND
THEN SIMULTANEOUSLY TAX IT ALL
AWAY AND TAKE IT ALL BACK.
THESE ARE, HOW DID WE GET 535 OF
THE DUMBEST PEOPLE IN AMERICA TO
ALL GET ELECTED TO OFFICE IN
D.C. AT THE WASHINGTON AT THE
SAME TIME.
HOW DID WE, WHO IS THE GENIUS
WHOSE SITTING IN A BOARDROOM IN
WASHINGTON D.C. SOMEWHERE, OR
UP ON CAPITOL HILL SAYING I’VE
GOT A BETTER IDEA, AS WE’RE
GIVING PEOPLE MONEY TO TAX IT
BACK LET’S OPEN THE SOUTHERN
BORDER IN THE MIDDLE OF A
PANDEMIC BECAUSE THIS IS A
SPECTACULAR IDEA FOR AMERICAN
PROSPERITY.
THERE IS NOTHING BETTER THAN
THIS AND DOES ANYONE IN THAT
ROOM, ANYONE SAY FOLKS, I HAVE A
QUESTION?
I’M GOING TO RAISE MY HAND.
NOT ONLY ARE WE IN THE MIDDLE OF
A PANDEMIC, BUT YOU KNOW, WE
HAVE THIS WHOLE NATIONAL
SECURITY THING WE’VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT WHERE WE SHOULD
PROBABLY VET PEOPLE COMING INTO
THE COUNTRY AND EVERYBODIES LIKE
LOOK AT THIS IDIOT, NATIONAL
SECURITY PANDEMIC, BORDERS, WHO
NEEDS ANY OF THAT CRAP?
I MEAN, WE’RE WATCHING THE
COLLAPSE OF THE GREATEST
COUNTRY IN THE HISTORY OF HUMAN
KIND AND AGAIN, 535 OF THE
DUMBEST PEOPLE HUMANITY HAS
EVER OFFERED UP ARE ALL SITTING
IN D.C. RIGHT NOW, GOING OVER
THE ENTIRE PROCESS LIKE IT’S
LIKE THE  HOBBETT LORD OF THE
RINGS.
HOW DID WE ELECT SUCH MORONS?
IS THIS HARD?
WE HAVE A BORDER.
IS THERE A COUNTRY IN THE
HISTORY OF HUMAN KIND THAT
DIDN’T HAVE A BORDER?
DO YOU KNOW WHAT YOU HAVE IF YOU
DON’T HAVE A BORDER?
YOU HAVE A LAND MASS.
YOU HAVE A SUGGESTION.
YOU DON’T HAVE A COUNTRY.
JUST CLOSE THE BORDER AND SAY
HEY, YOU WANT TO COME IN?
THERE’S THE DOOR.
THERE’S THIS THING CALLED A
PROCESS, SORRY, GUYS BUT MY WIFE
DID IT.
IT’S NOT HARD.
YOU GO IN, MY WIFE SAID --
AINSLEY: HOW DOES SHE FEEL?
>> I’VE GOT ONE MORE BECAUSE MY
WIFE, IT’S NOT HARD.
MY WIFE AND I ARE VERY SMART,
BUT WE DIDN’T INVENT THE THEORY
OF RELATIVITY LIKE EINSTEIN.
MY WIFE WENT INTO THE
IMMIGRATION PLACE AND SAID
I’M A COLOMBIAN CITIZEN AND I
MARRIED THIS AMERICAN GUY, HE’S
NOT AS SMART AS ME, BUT I’D LIKE
TO BE A CITIZEN, AND THEY GO
OKAY, HERE IS THE PROCESS.
GUYS HERE IS WHAT’S EVEN CRAZIER
, IT WORKED.
MY WIFE IS AN AMERICAN CITIZEN,
THERE IS A PROCESS.
AINSLEY: WHAT DOES SHE SAY?
I AM CURIOUS, WHAT DOES SHE SAY
WHEN SHE SEES THE IMAGES BECAUSE
MY HEARTBREAKS ALL OF OUR HEARTS
BREAK WHEN WE SEE THESE BABIES
COMING ACROSS AND MOMS WILLING
TO TRAVEL FOR 22 DAYS, KEVIN
MCCARTHY SAID HE TALKED TO
SOMEONE THAT TRAVELED FOR 22
DAYS TO GET TO THE BORDER.
OF COURSE WHERE HUMAN BEINGS,
OUR HEARTS BREAK FOR THEM BUT
I’M CURIOUS WHAT DOES YOUR WIFE
SAY ABOUT THAT BECAUSE THEY’RE
NOT DOING IT THE RIGHT WAY.
>> MY WIFE AND MY MOTHER-IN-LAW
IS ACTUALLY MORE INTERESTING,
LISTEN, I LOVE MY WIFE TO DEATH
BUT SHE WORKS ON MY SHOW SO SHE
PRETTY MUCH LIKE WHATEVER I SAY
SHE GOES ALONG WITH ON THE SHOW,
BUT SHE ONLY HAS STRONG OPINIONS
TOO ON THIS BUT MY MOTHER-IN-LAW
IS LIKE I DON’T GET THIS.
LIKE WHY, I ALWAYS THINK OF A
STORY MY MOTHER-IN-LAW COMES
HERE FROM COLOMBIA, DOESN’T
SPEAK A WORD OF ENGLISH I DON’T
KNOW SHE HAD $10 IN HER WALLET
AND SHE’S NOW WORTH A PRETTY
GOOD CHUNK OF CHANGE BECAUSE SHE
DID THIS CRAZY THING CALLED
WORKING AND INVESTED IN HER
MONEY AND SCORED ON A FEW REAL
ESTATE DEALS, BUT SHE DOES OKAY
FOR HERSELF AND I REMEMBER THE
STORY THEY CAME HERE AND
SLEPT IN A ONE BEDROOM APARTMENT
IN JACKSON, HEIGHTS AND THEY
SLEPT HEADS/TAILS WHEN YOU HAVE
ONLY ONE MATTRESS AND THREE KIDS
SO YOU GOT TO SLEEP FOOT-TO-HEAD
BECAUSE THERE’S NO OTHER ROOM
AND IT’S MORE CONVENIENT TO PACK
THEM IN.
>> LAWRENCE: SHE’S A HARD
WORKING WOMAN AND YOU KNOW I
ADORE YOUR WIFE, DAN.
>> I KNOW, BUT SHE SAYS BECAUSE
THEY SLEPT HEADS/TAILS ON THE
MATTRESS, LAWRENCE SHE SAID
I HEARD MY DAUGHTER TALKING
ABOUT MY WIFE NOW, I USED TO
HEAR MY DAUGHTER’S STOMACH AT
NIGHT BECAUSE I COULDN’T AFFORD
ANY FOOD.
YOU THINK ABOUT THAT WHEN SHE
WENT THROUGH THE RIGHT WAY AND
NOW YOU WANT TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
MY MOTHER IN LAW IS SO PISSED
OFF THAT EVERYONE ELSE IS LIKE
OH, SCREW IT.
THE RIGHT WAY?
WE’RE JUST GOING TO WALK IN AND
DO WHATEVER WE WANT.
YOU UNDERSTAND WHY LEGAL
IMMIGRANTS TO THIS COUNTRY, YOU
WANT TO KNOW WHY DONALD TRUMP
DID SO WELL AMONGST VENEZUELANS,
AND OTHER HISPANIC IMMIGRANTS
THAT CAME TO THIS COUNTRY, NOT
JUST CUBAN AMERICANS IN SOUTHERN
FLORIDA MAYBE IT’S BECAUSE YOU
TREAT THEM LIKE IDIOTS DEMOCRATS
MAYBE BECAUSE THE PEOPLE THAT
CAME HERE, HISPANIC IMMIGRANTS
AND OTHERS WHO ARE HARD WORKING
ARE LIKE HEY I DID IT THE RIGHT
WAY THIS IS A COUNTRY OF RULES
AND PROCESS AND ORDER AND IF
YOU’RE NOT WILLING TO DO THAT
FIRST, THEN YOU’RE NOT WILLING
TO BE AN AMERICAN BECAUSE
AMERICA IS ABOUT LAW AND ORDER
AND PROCESS AND YOUR FIRST STEP
WAS TO IGNORE THAT.
NOW YOU UNDERSTAND WHY THEY ARE
A LITTLE PISSED OFF?
THAT’S WHY.
>> LAWRENCE: AND THOSE
IMMIGRANTS ALSO DON’T LIKE
THE DIRECTION OF THE COUNTRY AND
THEY DON’T LIKE THIS SOCIAL
JUSTICE WARRIOR NONSENSE, THEY
DON’T LIKE THAT WE’RE BECOMING
MORE LIKE THE COUNTRIES THAT
THEY FLED FROM.
THEY ARE UPSET AND THIS IS WHY
THE PRESIDENT MADE GAINS AS YOU
CORRECTLY SAID, DAN, THANKS SO
MUCH FOR JOINING US TODAY.